former U.S president Donald Trump has
been indicted for the fourth time
prosecutors in the state of Georgia have
charged him and his associates accusing
them of conspiring to overturn the
results of the 2020 election the
defendants include his former lawyer and
a former white house chief of staff John
hendron has the story from the state
capitol Atlanta
for the fourth time a grand jury has
indicted former president Donald Trump
for alleged crimes against the country
he governed thank you leading this
series of indictments against Trump and
others racketeering a charge that
usually targets organized crime rings in
this case for an alleged conspiracy to
steal the state's presidential election
the indictment alleges
that rather than abide abide by
Georgia's legal process for election
challenges the defendants engaged in a
criminal racketeering Enterprise to
overturn Georgia's presidential election
result
also indicted 18 others including former
white house chief of staff Mark Meadows
Trump lawyer Rudolph Giuliani former
justice department official Jeffrey
Clark and former aide John Eastman the
alleged conspiracy included a series of
phone calls in which Trump pressured
Georgia officials to overturn Joe
Biden's presidential election victory in
the state including this notorious call
to Secretary of State Brad raffensberger
I do just want to find
780 votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state that alleged
conspiracy also included false
accusations and harassment of election
workers including Ruby Freeman who said
she had to go into hiding after Trump
fans invaded her grandmother's home to
make what they called a citizen's arrest
it also contained false allegations of
ballot fraud
the alleged plant also contained a fake
elector scheme in which trump-backed
electors tried to form a false slate of
electors who sought to flip the state of
Georgia for Trump after his loss
and it involved an extraordinary data
breach in rural Coffee County where
Trump partisans were called in to scan
votes in a fruitless search for massive
fraud Georgia was just one of several
States Trump would have needed to win to
win the 2020 election but Georgia was a
special case it tended to lean
Republican and he lost by a small margin
a margin he asked Georgia State
Republicans to make up to overturn his
loss there
the Trump campaign issued a lengthy
statement stating in part they could
have brought this two and a half years
ago and they chose to do this for
election interference reasons in the
middle of President Trump's successful
campaign the indictment is the fourth in
as many months Trump faces State charges
in New York for a hush money payment to
silence a porn star ahead of the 2016
election and two federal indictments in
Florida for mishandling classified
documents and in Washington for his
efforts to overturn the 2020 election
unlike the federal charges if proved the
Georgia state charges cannot be pardoned
by the next president John hendron Al
Jazeera Atlanta
Brendan O'Connor is a professor of
American politics at the University of
Sydney Brendan you're joining us from
Australia look it would be easy to lose
count at this stage of trump indictments
but we can't lose track of the fact that
this is completely unprecedented put
that in context for us please
well democracy relies upon Losers of
Elections presidential candidates
accepting the result you can't say
you're for democracy only when you win
and Donald Trump was clearly in breach
of the American Constitution he was in
breach of the basic principle of the
American electoral system of democracy
that if you do not win the electoral
college you do not win the election and
he clearly lost the state of Georgia
there's just overwhelming evidence that
he lost it by a reasonably significant
margin and he wished to through a
conspiracy this is what the charges are
about today he wished to overturn what
was the will of the people and in any
serious democracy this should lead to
Serious investigation and these charges
I think are entirely Justified as a
result
Donald Trump and his campaign are
fundraising off of these indictments
every time there are new Criminal
indictments his campaign raises more
money is it fair to say at this stage
this is actually helping fueling his
campaign at least the primary run we'll
get to the general election later
no pressure yeah I think the basic point
I'd make is it's the right thing to do
to charge Trump no matter what the
outcome I think that to sweep this under
the carpet and say look it's all
political the timing's not right he has
to be charged maybe it would have been
preferable if these charges were earlier
uh in 2021 or 2022 but a lot of evidence
has been gathered of a tight case in
many regards a major case a kind of a
criminal conspiracy RICO law quite sort
of ironically something Rudy Giuliani
when he was mayor of New York developed
for criminal syndicates in New York city
so the election results of this uh you
know to be determined it surely is
incredible publicity for Trump because
he will play on the sense of victimhood
uh he's always played on the idea that
sort of white men in America are the one
some of the most discriminated against
people probably not the truthful not
truthfully the case and the majority of
instances but he's very much played on
himself as as a victim as a martyr and
this will help with that but it is still
the right thing to do to charge him for
this criminal conspiracy because he is
trying to bribe and intimidate election
officials he's trying to come up with uh
false electors all sorts of things which
uh fundamentally would undermine America
as a Democratic Society so about that
last point you make Brendan in this
particular case we've all heard that
phone call if this you know you don't
need to be an acute legal mind to
understand what's going on here is that
phone call between Trump and an election
official in Georgia where he asks him to
quote unquote find those are his words
find eleven thousand plus votes and that
does not appear at least in the primary
run to be hurting him
no I mean I think people have factored
in the sense of believing Trump or not
really caring as I said before the
democracy is a good idea when you win
but not when you lose so I think Trump
you know and this would be a problem
with the jurists that there will be
people who will believe or want to
believe uh what Trump's defense teams
say that there's basically they've
chosen a team and Donald Trump is their
team no matter what the evidence so this
immunity to something like you know the
tape is a would be called a Smoking Gun
in most uh legal or political corruption
scandals but it we have to factor in as
we did with covert that you know there
are people in the face of enormous
evidence with global warming who will
just say no the opposite is true because
my side says the opposite is true and so
therefore Trump you know is is very much
in a position to be able to look to
politicize this to politicize the jury
and when whether this case will in fact
you know occur in six months whether it
will occur before the next election I
mean that I suppose is my biggest
concern even though State cases can't be
easily dismissed by a president uh
there'll be a lot of things if Trump has
elected president and sworn into office
um in January 20 in 2025 that he'll be
able to do to ensure that he doesn't
come to trial Brendan O'Connor professor
of American politics at the University
of Sydney thank you for joining us today
my pleasure